it was a race against time
these british holidaymakers arrived on
the last eurostar from france
into saint pancreas international just
hours before new quarantine restrictions
came into force
and for those who made it back in time
there was relief
i can't do another two weeks inside i've
i've got things to do back home
i'm not doing another two weeks inside
no thank you actually deciding what to
do
was very stressful and seeing how like
going on the website and seeing just
all the tickets just disappearing like
very very
fast i had to spend 200 quid last night
to
get the 260 i think because there
weren't any like normal tickets as well
left so i had to spend 260 quid to get
back
home it's a very stressful time for you
yeah i mean i don't have that money to
spend
for much of friday the dash to get home
was relentless
tickets were sold out in their thousands
for the euro tunnel
ferries increased in capacity and plane
tickets for some flights to the uk
had doubled in price on a trip from
cairns this family spent a total
of 1500 pounds as much as we were aware
of the risks as much as we knew it could
happen
you know overnight or instantly i'm just
a little bit surprised we weren't given
even another 12 hours on top of what we
have
um but as i say we've we've made it work
we've got
a route home um and we've had our three
days in the sun so
we can't be too bitter about it i don't
think two weeks ago france reported
19 cases per 100 000 people
today that number is 32 per 100
000 a jump of more than two-thirds
the restrictions which are now in place
will also apply to those returning
from other destinations such as malta
the netherlands
and monaco some holiday makers are
worried about what comes next
and how the next few weeks will play out
but the advice from the government
is clear it will act if it needs to
in order to tackle krovet 19
no phillips sky news